ce moment steven corneille en assistant
vétérinaire l'attendait il peut enfin
tenter de trouver un rendez vous pour
aller se faire vacciner contre la
corrida comme tous les français qui ont
plus de 18 ans une seule condition il
faut que les doses soient disponibles la
veille pour le lendemain
donc les rendez-vous sont confirmées
chez la possibilité du coup de déplacer
les rendez vous dès supprimés
une agréable surprise que ce rendez vous
alors que la plateforme d'octo lim a
enregistré 23 millions de recherches
pour quelques 21000 créneaux disponibles
mardi
c'est un peu comme gagner à la lotto
j'espère juste que tout le monde
arrivera à le faire est qu'on enlèvera
un petit peu avancé à sortir de tout ça
l'accélération de la campagne de
vaccination est la bienvenue ici on en
est très content mais on a perdu
beaucoup de temps parce que il ya cette
culture de gens qui n'ont pas le goût
qui n'ont pas l'aptitude la compétence à
agir sur le terrain à résoudre les
problèmes c'est une autre forme
d'intelligence
transformer le vélodrome de saint
quentin en vaccinodromes c'était son
idée du coni minutes six mois l'équipe
de france si on traîne toujours pour les
jeux olympiques de tokyo
il faudra une fois de plus le réaménager
pour permettre dès cette fin de semaine
quatre mille injection quotidienne alors
que la capacité actuelle est de 2 à 3000
le gouvernement souhaite atteindre les
20 millions de primo vaccination d'ici
samedi
un objectif qui sera difficile at plus
vite plus vite répète sans cesse le
premier ministre jean castex il faut
vacciner tous les jours même les
dimanches et les jours fériés
pourtant ce jeudi fête de l'ascension
les deux tiers des centres de
vaccination seront fermés y compris
celui ci dans les yvelines parce
qu'après plusieurs mois à frire du temps
pour la campagne de vaccination le
personnel mobilisé es fatigué on est
tous fatigués c'est normal mais je pense
qu'on a encore quelques quelques
semaines et quelques mois à tenir à ce
rythme là donc il faut y aller pas trop
se poser de questions et puis se dire
qu'on oeuvre pour la population si la
campagne de vaccination est en dessous
des objectifs du gouvernement c'est
aussi à cause de la méfiance persistante
envers le vaccin astrazeneca réservé aux
gens de plus de 55 ans seulement 75% des
doses reçues ont été injectés selon des
chiffres publiés dimanche dernier
steven nuit pourra profiter du long
congé pour se reposer le coeur plus
léger
une première dose en poche c'est aussi
la promesse de deuxième rendez-vous à
suri dans six semaines le délai observé
par la france trop tard pour la
réouverture des terrasses et des
commerces la semaine prochaine mais
juste à temps pour les vacances
estivales ici marie-eve bédard
radio-canada 50